[موسيقى]
في الاحساء الفلكلور الرمضاني متنوع ما
بين التجمع داخل برك السباحه في المزارع
وحضور الديوانيات والامسيات مساء حتى وقت
السحور الاول في رمضان الصباح بدري بدري
طال عمرك هايدي طبيعي ما في الا اذا احتد
الحر اذا جاء رمضان في حار
يريحون الصباح شوي يريحون اخر النهار شوف
العالم متنقعين في البراك وفي
الاعيان هذه الموجوده في الاحساء كل شيء
يشبه النخيل تاريخها اجوائها واهلها ما
ابكر يا طويل العمر اني حتى دمام وصلت
الدمام صدق لي عشر سنوات ما وصلت الدمام
مال العلم عندي اختي واخوي مو على انها
قطعه رحم لا والله هم يجونا كل اسبوع على
فكره عشان الوالد وعشان امي العم صلاح
المهيني يحن كثيرا الى عادات شهر رمضان
المبارك قديما
انقطع اي والله هذا طبيله اي نعم احنا
كل شيء موجود اول لازم نربط بين
تقريبا قبل قبل الساحه تقريبا ساعه بساعه
ونص صح ولا لا صح
لا ما في
لا تخلو منها شوارع الاحساء بسطات الكبده
التي باتت عاده الرمضانيه الى جانب الكثير
من الاكلات الشعبيه طبعا جزء لا يتجزا من
المائده الرمضانيه في الحسا
اساسي وكل يوم كل يوم حطله زاد سووا شوربه
في الليل كوسا قرع خضره مشكل من جميع كله
على حسب
كل الفوائد موجوده هنا
ولازم يشبع بالمول لازم يشبع بالموت
[موسيقى]
لا صحيح
عبد الرحمن العصيمي من الاحساء العربيه